For the past 9 minutes the Space Shuttle has
been powering its way through the atmosphere.
Propelled forward by 2 massive solid rocket
boosters, completing their duties 2 minutes
into the flight, they are now falling back
to earth where they will be refurbished and
reused.
The final push comes from the orbiter's 3
main engines, being fed liquid oxygen and
liquid hydrogen from the colossal orange external
tank at an astonishing rate.
Having drained the 700 tonnes of fuel and
oxidiser from its tanks the time has come
to shut down the powerful main engines and
jettison the external tank.
The astronauts inside the orbiter will find
themselves transitioning from a exilerating
thundering journey to a serene silent cruise,
becoming weightless the moment the engines
power down.
The light of the shining blue earth below
them flood through the windows of the crew
cabin.
The journey to orbit has ended, but their
mission has just begun.
The space shuttle was not just a rocket, it
was a mobile laboratory, a home in space,
and it came with all the tools the astronauts
needed to not just survive , but to complete
complicated tasks in space.
A sanctuary amidst the unforgiving expanse
of space, the orbiter provided a secure haven,
sustaining a breathable atmosphere, facilitating
precise maneuvers, a payload bay capable of
carrying massive spacecraft like the Hubble
Space Telescope, and the machinery needed
to repair them when needed.
This is the insane engineering of the Space
Shuttle Orbiter
The astronauts' jobs begin the moment they
reach orbit.
The orbiter has released the external tank
and it’s beginning its journey back through
the atmosphere where it will disintegrate.
This is the last view anyone will have of
the external tank intact, and it was vital
that photos were taken of it to check for
any issues that could have occurred on ascent.
To do this the commander of the orbiter needs
to pitch the shuttle onto its back using its
maneuvering system.
Scattered all over the orbiter are smaller
rocket nozzles, part of the reaction control
system.
This removable module in the nose of the aircraft
was the forward reaction control system.
[Footage]Inside there are two spherical tanks,
an oxidiser tank filled with nitrogen tetroxide
and a fuel tank filled with monomethyl hydrazine.
This fuel oxidiser combination is unique.
It doesn’t need an ignition source.
It’s hypergolic.
Meaning they spontaneously ignite upon contact
with each other.
But, both substances were extremely toxic.
Producing ominous orange clouds of toxic gas.
Breathing this in would cause your lungs to
rapidly fill with fluid, and once in your
bloodstream it interferes with the blood's
ability to carry oxygen.
Anyone working with the propellants had to
wear pressurized breathing suits to prevent
any chance of contact.
The astronauts also had exclusion zones around
these nozzles on space walks to prevent any
danger of the chemicals coming back aboard.
It’s an undesirable fuel to work with in
many ways, but its advantages were why it
was used.
These hypergolic fuels were extremely reliable,
igniting on contact with each other removed
any need for complicated ignition systems
that could fail.
[REF] They could be stored for longer periods
than cryogenic fuels that would have to be
continually vented as temperatures rose, which
makes cryogenic fuels unsuitable for longer
missions like the space shuttle, with the
longest space shuttle mission lasting 18 days
this was critical.
[FOOTAGE]
The propellants could also be quickly mixed
in precise volumes to provide precise and
instantaneous thrust control.
This was important when maneuvering in close
proximity to another spacecraft.
The propellants are fed into the combustion
chamber through pressurization of the tanks
with high pressure helium.
Held in spherical kevlar composite tanks with
titanium inner liners, an extremely lightweight
tank, just 10 kilograms in weight, but nearly
a half meter in diameter.
Spherical tanks are the most weight efficient
form of pressure vessel, with the highest
volume to weight ratio.
Ideally all rockets could use spherical tanks,
but ultimately diameters increase too much
as volume requirements rise and it’s preferable
to minimize the cross-sectional area of the
rocket to reduce drag.
There is no turbopump needed here; the back
pressure from the high pressure helium provides
enough flow rate for the purposes of these
low power rocket motors.
In the forward reaction control system pod
there are 12 main thrusters and there are
12 in each of the left and right rear pods
too.
For a total of 38 main thrusters, each capable
of providing 3870 newtons of thrust with a
specific impulse of 289 seconds.
Sometimes even finer control was needed for
delicate docking procedures
and for this the orbiter had 6 smaller vernier
thrusters capable of producing as little as
111 newtons.
The same amount of force you would need to
lift an 11 kilogram weight here on earth.
With a total of 44 reaction control thrusters
scattered around the orbiter the astronauts
needed a way to control them.
The controls were located at the commander's
seat on the left side of the cockpit and here
on the left side of the aft flight deck.
The rear position was added to allow the commander
to look out this rear window while maneuvering
for rendezvous with other spacecraft or releasing
payloads.
Each station had a square-knobbed controller
used for translational movements, in and out,
side to side and up and down.
And a more traditional flight stick, which
was used to control attitude, pitch, roll
and yaw.
[[REF]
There was also a flight computer where desired
attitude and velocity changes could be entered
with a keypad.
Of course this was all fly by wire the commanders
inputs were all fed into a computer which
interpreted the commands and decided the best
course of action.
There was only one notable exception to this
fly by wire system.
]
I mean, there is nothing mechanically linked
to any of the control surfaces or anything.
Everything goes through the computer, everything
you touch goes through the computer and the
computer generates everything.
We are concerned about things called single
event upset, and you've probably heard of
this before, where a cosmic ray comes in and
upsets the computers and you can recover from
anything.
But because there was no way to raise the
landing gear, we were concerned a single event
upset if there was an automatic computer way
to lower the wheels that you could get your
wheels lowered on orbit and not be able to
come home.
So we always made that mechanical.
And so once we got down to under 300 feet,
200 feet, that was the pilot's main job was
to lower the wheels manually.
Putting them back in place required ground
crew to push them back in.
So, because ionizing radiation in space could
potentially trigger the computers to lower
the landing gear, and with no way of raising
them back up, they were lowered manually.
The landing gears were held in place by a
hooked lock that was released
after the pilot flipped the protective covers
of these two buttons, an arming button and
button labeled “dn” for down.
When this happened a hydraulic actuator released
the hook holding the landing gears in place
and allowed them to lower.
The first day of the mission is now starting.
[REF] The astronauts begin their tasks.
The pilot and commander seated in the left
and right seats in front of the instrument
panel are busy working towards the first rendezvous
with intelsat.
Through the forward windows the astronauts
can glimpse a distant bright dot, the satellite
that they are maneuvering towards.
These weren’t the only windows on board,
there were additional overhead windows, along
with rear windows looking into the payload
bay, which for now remains closed.
These windows were key to the reusability
of the shuttle.
The windows had to be durable enough to survive
space debris impacts and capable of resisting
the temperatures of re-entry
The Space Shuttle's window structure had multiple
layers of glass, each tailored to withstand
different conditions.
The pressure pane was engineered to endure
the cabin pressure in space; it was made from
15.7 millimeters thick aluminosilicate glass
that was tempered to be mechanically strong.
On the outer edge of this pane, a red film
was added to reflect back the heat into the
vehicle to not be lost to space, while still
letting visible light through.
The outermost pane, or the thermal pane, was
also 15.7 millimeters thick and capable of
resisting temperatures up to 482 degrees celsius.
There was also a large space between these
two panes, which minimized heat transfer between
the outer shell and the inner crew cabin.
On one discovery mission one of these windows
was struck by space debris, leaving a small
crater in the window, but it did not break.
[Footage]
If it had, the astronauts inside were in no
danger, as there was a center redundant pane,
serving as a failsafe for both the thermal
and pressure panes.
It was 33 millimeters thick and made out of
fused silica glass the same material that
laboratory crucibles and beakers are made
of.
The rear windows looking into the payload
area did not have the outer thermal pane since
they would not be exposed to the extreme super
heated plasma during re-entry.
There were no windows in the middeck, below
the crew deck.
The middeck is where many of the science experiments
in orbit were performed, and this is where
the astronauts slept and ate.
There were stations where the astronauts could
strap themselves to the walls in the weightless
environment, but not everyone chose to use
them.
The commander and pilot generally slept up
on the flight deck that they would just loosely
strap themselves in their commander in pilot
seats because that was a good way, and you
want to be kind of strapped in.
There were some astronauts like story Musgrave
that liked to free float around in space,
but he would bump into people, and I heard
that it was quite annoying sometimes.
But the rest of us, you'd have a cloth sleeping
bag that's made out of just light material
like this where you velcro it to a bulkhead
or the ceiling and you just zip yourself up
in it.
The time has now come to open the payload
doors.
The doors needed to open shortly after reaching
orbit as one of the space shuttles vital life
support systems required them to be open.
The temperature control system.
Two radiator panels are attached to each of
the forward payload bay doors.
Freon filled tubes snake around these panels.
Where they radiate heat absorbed from a heat
exchanger located inside the orbiter into
space.
The payload doors themselves are made from
a graphite/epoxy composite material which
reduced the weight of the doors by 408 kilograms
over a comparable aluminium design.
At the time this was the largest aerospace
composite structure ever made.
[Page 173]
Covering the payload bay which was 18.3 meters
long and 4.6 meters wide.
The largest and heaviest payload it ever carried
was on STS-93 with the Chandra X-Ray Observatory
coming in at 22.7 tonnes.
Maxing out the shuttle's capacity.
This mission came worryingly close to disaster.
During each refurbishment of the shuttles
main engines, they were inspected with ultrasound
[REF] to find signs of damage.
In some cases damage may be detected in one
of the liquid oxygen posts that delivered
liquid oxygen to the combustion chamber, and
instead of replacing the entire expensive
and difficult to manufacture injection assembly,
the post was simply deactivated with a gold
pin that plugged the channel.
During the pre-launch start up sequence of
the main shuttle engines on STS-93
one of these gold pins was ejected out and
struck the hydrogen coolant channels in the
nozzle, resulting in a hydrogen leak that
you can actually see here in images of the
launch.
The engine detected a decrease in combustion
chamber pressure, and opened the oxidiser
valve to increase thrust, the engine had no
way of knowing the issue was a hydrogen leak.
It could only detect the drop in combustion
chamber pressure and respond by making the
combustion less fuel rich, which increases
thrust and temperature.
This incident resulted in a maintenance policy
switch that meant damaged oxygen posts had
to be replaced and not simply plugged.
Thankfully the engine survived and the mission
was successfully completed despite the main
engines shutting down prematurely
as a result of the oxygen depletion sensors
being triggered.
So the orbiter was 4.6 m/s off it’s target
orbital velocity.
Thankfully the Orbiter has an orbital maneuvering
system that could bring it up to its desired
velocity
These large rocket nozzles were not part of
the reaction control system, and were capable
of providing 305 meters per second of additional
velocity.
Powered by the same hypergolic fuel and oxidiser
as the RCS system, from tanks hidden within
the OMS pods, capable of holding 4 tonnes
of fuel and 6.7 tonnes of oxidiser.
When performing large orbital changes like
this it was important for the Space Shuttle
to know precisely where it was,
and to do this it could open these doors on
the left side of the orbiter's nose, revealing
the star tracker optics.
These star trackers analyzed positions of
the stars in the sky to determine exactly
where the orbiter was, allowing it to precisely
navigate in orbit.
Once the space shuttle has arrived at its
target orbit, the real work can begin.
On Bruce’s mission, STS 49, the first task
was to rendezvous with that stranded communications
satellite.
Carefully maneuvering the orbiter closer to
the satellite as the satellite's operators
attempted to stabilize its spin.
As they approached 2 astronauts.
Pierre Thout and Richard Hieb donned their
EVA suits in the middeck and prepared to enter
the airlock.
The airlock for this mission was located inside
the crew cabin of the middeck,but it could
be configured to be outside in the payload
area.
During the construction of the international
space station, a special docking system was
also installed, which was required to allow
the space shuttle to dock to both Russian
and American spacecraft.
It was called the androgynous peripheral attach
system.
The androgynous name comes from the fact that
both the target and the receiving end look
identical, with no male or female parts, with
the goal of this being a universal docking
system allowing any two spacecraft to dock
together.
As Goddard intended.
Each side had a ring with three petals equally
distributed.
One side extended its mating ring for a soft
capture, where the 3 petals of each side come
together and connect with these latches.
[REF]
At this point, the soft capture ring is retracted
and 12 latches engage to form an airtight
connection between the two spacecraft.
This system was used extensively during the
construction of the international space station,
which the space shuttle had an instrumental
role in transporting and assembling in space.
Including the very first modules to be connected
in 1998 on STS 88, when the orbiter docked
with the Russian Zarya module using this docking
ring, and proceeded to connect the unity module.
On STS-49, Bruce’s mission, the stranded
satellite was never intended to be docked
with and had no docking points, and thus to
capture the stranded satellite the astronauts
needed to perform an EVA and manually grab
the satellite using a capture bar specifically
designed for this mission, but not everything
went to plan
So we made several attempts to grab this satellite
with the capture bar, but every time Pierre
touched the bottom of the satellite with the
capture bar, it bounced off out of control.
Fortunately, the engineers that owned Intel
sat, they could send commands back up to it,
restabilize it so we could maneuver back closer
to it and try again.
So we tried three or four times the first
day to grab it every time it bounced off.
Second day we tried again every time it bounced
off.
So at that point we were kind of at a loss.
We didn't know what we were going to do.
And of course, all this time, I'm operating
the arm.
I'm chasing the satellite with Pierre on the
end of it.
And so it was a very demanding part of the
flight.
So two days of trying the ground said, okay,
we're going to take the third day off, and
then we're go back out and try on the fourth
day to do it again.
Well, of course we felt like the mission was
lost.
So the ground told us, go ahead, get a good
night's sleep, we'll call you in the morning.
So we got to thinking, and matter of fact,
I saw that I could hear that Dan and Chile
were talking up on the flight deck when we
were supposed to be asleep.
So I floated up to the flight deck with them
and they were talking about how Endeavor was
so maneuverable and was so efficient on its
fuel burn that they thought we could get close
enough to the satellite to where Rick and
Pierre could just grab it with their gloved
hands.
And we saw it at one point when Pierre got
the capture bar, one side of the capture bar
fired, and it almost immediately stopped the
rotation.
So we knew that it was going to be easy to
stop the rotation if Rick and Pierre could
just grab the bottom of the satellite.
The problem was is now what do you do if you
do grab the satellite?
You've got two guys out there holding a 9,000
pound satellite with no way to get it back
on the rocket motor that we took up to strap
to it to send it back up to the proper orbit.
Well, I scratched my head while I was up there
and I knew that because after we finished
this satellite business, two other astronauts,
Tom Akers and Kathy Thornton, they were going
to go out and do some practice of assembly
of the Space station.
We hadn't built the space station at that
point, and they were going to be out trying
to do some methods for that.
Well, in order to accommodate all the different
sized astronauts, the EVA suits or the spacewalking
suits, they're made out of different components,
different length arms, different size torsos,
those sorts of things.
And Rick Hebe is this big, Kathy Thornton
was this tall, and then Tom and Pierre are
about my size.
So in order to accommodate four astronauts
on two different spacewalks of those different
sizes, we for the first time ever had three
full EVA suit, the components of three full
EVA suits on board.
So I got to thinking, I said, well, we have
three suits on board.
Why don't we send three space walkers out?
We can have two people grab it and then one
person put the capture bar on because the
capture bar had to be attached to the satellite
because that was what was going to attach
it to the rocket motor that we brought up.
However, this plan had one problem.
The airlock was only designed for two people.
The airlock consisted of two air tight doors.
Once inside, with the doors sealed, the astronauts
could depressurize the inside by venting the
air to space.
This could only be done from inside the hatch,
but repressurization could be done from outside
and inside.
For obvious safety reasons.
This process took about 30 minutes and while
it happened the astronauts were connected
to life support umbilicals so they didn't
have to waste their internal supplies during
the wait.
This was the first problem.
There were only 2 life support umbilicals
available.
It was also going to be a tight squeeze for
three astronauts with full EVA gear on, as
the cylindrical airlock inside the mid-deck
was just 160 centimeters in diameter and 210
centimeters high.
The third astronaut was going to need to make
some sacrifices.
So unlike normally where you just have two
astronauts, you put 'em in the airlock, you
close the door with Tom,
he had to go on all of his internal controls
and we float him in the airlock upside down.
So now you've got Rick and Pierre right side
up, and Tom Akers head down in the airlock,
and he's on his internal systems now where
Rick and Pierre are still attached to the
umbilicals inside, close the airlock evacuate
it, and then all three of them floated out.
And here, the three astronauts got to work.
With Bruce on the remote manipulator arm controls
inside the orbiter, and he was chosen for
a very specific reason.
He was a coast guard helicopter pilot.
And the reason Dan wanted to have a Coast
Guard helicopter pilot on the arm, and the
reason for that is, is that operating the
arm, the controls that you use are vaguely
similar to operating a helicopter because
in a helicopter you have to fly with both
hands and both feet.
Well, when you're operating the arm, you've
got two controllers, you've got a rotational
hand controller and a translational hand controller.
So the translational hand controller, you
move up, down, sideways, in and out.
Rotational hand controller controls the attitude
of the arm.
So it's very much flying a helicopter and
you can't be thinking about it when you're
in a very tight situation.
You've got to be the arm.
The canadarm, named after its country of origin,
was a multifunctional tool used for many tasks
aboard the shuttle.
A simple articulated arm may not seem overly
impressive, but the unique physics of a weightless
environment and desire to minimize the launch
weight of the space shuttle made for a very
interesting engineering challenge.
The entire 15 meter long arm weighs just 430
kilograms, and despite being able to move
30 tonnes in orbit, it couldn’t even hold
up its own weight on earth.
[REF]
The booms were made from low weight epoxy
graphite composite, with 6 joints.
2 joints at its shoulder for yaw and pitch,
1 elbow pitch joint, and 3 joints at the wrist
for yaw, pitch and roll.
For a total of 6 degrees of freedom of movement,
exactly like your own arm.
However your elbow joint is only capable of
about 140 degrees of pitch before your biceps
get in the way.
The Canadarms elbow joint rotational axis
is offset by 0.15 meters to allow up to 160
degrees of rotation.
[REF]
Because the arm is working in a weightless
environment motors don’t need to be able
to apply that much torque.
Each motor could produce 0.7 newton meters
of torque.
With no friction in space a small force can
move any mass, it just depends how long you
want it to take.
In the same way an ion thruster with thrusts
of just 25 millinewtons could theoretically
get a spacecraft up to lightspeed if it had
enough propellant.
However, the dangers of inertia are still
real.
If a satellite was moving quickly relative
to the arm it could easily bend and break
the arm.
So slow delicate movement is the name of the
game and the motor can work in reverse to
assist each joint's brake system.
The loaded arm speed had a maximum speed of
just 6 centimeters per second.
The arm had a unique end fixture designed
to grapple onto attachment points on satellites.
However, because the intelsat was never intended
to be rendezvoused with, it didn't have any
grapple points installed.
So the capture bar had an attachment point
for the second stage rocket and had a grapple
point allowing the canadarm to grab hold of
it once it was securely attached.
The grapple point is a simple metallic pin
with three lobes at its base.
[REF]
This is all the arm needed to firmly grab
onto the intelsat.
The end effector of the canadarm used a naturally
self centering wire grapple system to hold
onto this pin.
Three wires, each anchored at two points.
One point is stationary, while the secondary
anchor point is attached to a rotating ring.
[REF]
Once Bruce had maneuvered the arm over the
grapple rod using the camera feed this rotating
ring would turn and ensnare the pin, pulling
it to the center.
The pin is then pulled inwards until the three
lobes at its base lock into corresponding
cut outs on the outside grabble ring.
A simple, but effective mechanism.
With the satellite now secure the three astronauts
could get to work attaching the new second
stage to the capture bar, which they did successfully,
allowing intelsat to raise itself to geostationary
orbit where it operated for 21 years.
STS 49 had another mission to complete.
A test run of space shuttle building techniques,
but with their time in orbit running out.
That mission lost a day.
Life support systems onboard were supplied
with enough gasses for the planned duration
of the mission.
Spherical tanks in the mid fuselage contained
high pressure oxygen and nitrogen.
With 3 nitrogen tanks and 1 oxygen.
Used to create a breathable atmosphere of
80% nitrogen and 20% oxygen.
Of course carbon dioxide needed to be scrubbed
from the air, and this was
done by passing the cabin air through lithium
hydroxide canisters located underneath the
middeck.
These solid canisters would react with the
CO2 to remove it from the atmosphere and create
water in the process.
This was not a renewable solution so every
12 hours the crew would access and replace
these canisters through this hatch on the
middeck bay.
There were also oxygen and hydrogen tanks
used for the space shuttles power system.
A fuel cell that reacted the hydrogen and
oxygen to produce water and electricity.
These powered everything on board, and produced
water in the process.
But this water carried some extra hydrogen
gas, so before the water could be used it
had to go through a process of degassing,
which separates the hydrogen and dumps it
overboard.
It was now time to prepare for re-entry and
the first step was closing those payload doors,
but on STS 49 another problem was encountered.
The payload doors would not latch due to thermal
warping of the doors, requiring some creative
problem solving.
Well, there's always two astronauts trained
to do EVAs and I was trained to do an EVA
on my first flight, and that's for a contingency.
If for example, the payload bay doors wouldn't
close or latch all the way when you're on
orbit, we have special tools where we could
winch 'em closed and latch 'em all together.
And matter of fact, on STS 49 after we had
trouble getting the satellite to launch because
of a different switch configuration, we got
up there and the payload bay doors wouldn't
close all the way.
And so we thought, oh man, do we need to go
back out and do that?
So your first attempt to fix something like
that is the thermal loads on the space shuttle.
As you can imagine, you're 200 degrees on
the sunny side and 200 degrees below zero
on the dark side.
So a lot of times you'll get a little bit
of an oil canning effect or a little twisting
of the fuselage just because of the thermal
effects.
And that's what we did.
We went ahead into what we call the barbecue
mode and we started, so we went ahead and
orbited the earth and the barbecue mode to
try to equalize the temperatures on the shuttle
when we couldn't get the payload bay doors
to close all the way.
And
When you say barbecue mode, do you mean like
a spit roast?
It's rotating,
Yes.
Yeah, it's not that fast, but you do that
to where you try to equally heat while you're
going through the sun and through the dark.
And I think it was just one or, but we had
to do, and we tried to close the doors again
and they latched.
With the doors successfully closed, the space
shuttle can begin its preparations to re-enter
the earth's atmosphere.
Firing the OMS engines once more to slow the
orbital velocity and slowly bring it back
into earth’s atmosphere.
At the moment of reentry, the space shuttle
will be traveling between 7 and 8 km/s.
Entering the thin upper atmosphere at 30 times
the speed of sound.
A speed so great that it begins to rip air
molecules apart, creating a glowing cloud
of charged plasma around the lower surface
of the orbiter.
With peak temperatures reaching 1650 degree
celsius (3000 F).
To not only withstand this immense heat, but
to transition to a glider capable of landing
on a runway required some incredible innovative
engineering.
Combining aerospace and aviation technologies
like never before.
A true space plane.
Episode 3 of the insane engineering of the
space shuttle, detailing the engineering of
re-entry and landing will be uploaded in the
coming weeks as we take a short break to celebrate
the holidays with our friends and family.
You are likely doing the same and perhaps
you are looking for a thoughtful gift for
the enthusiastic learners in your life, or
perhaps you want to set some new years goals
and learn some valuable skills
Brilliant can help you with both.
Brilliant makes learning easy with fun, interactive
courses that really succeed in getting you
that dopamine rush as they test your knowledge
along the way.
They have a fantastic mobile app so you can
learn on the go too.
I just completed the course teaching how large
language models like chatgpt work.
With the prevalence of that technology ever
growing, learning about how it works is incredibly
valuable.
Or perhaps you want to get ahead in university
and learn some valuable engineering skills
like how to use vectors to describe motions
in both engineering and computer science.
Brilliant has thousands of other lessons too.
AI, data science, neural networks and even
our very own partnered Real Engineering course.
You can get access to that course right now,
and all of Brilliant's other curated interactive
courses, by going to brilliant.org/RealEngineering
or by clicking the link in the description.
You can get started for free for 30 days,
and the first 500 people to do so will get
20% off Brilliant's annual premium subscription